psa recrute et veut le faire savoir
des affiches géantes ont été placardées
un peu partout autour du site de vesoul
nous recherchons entre 250 et 350
personnes aujourd'hui d'ici les premiers
mois de 2000 vingt ans les contrats nous
utilisons toute la plage qui est
possible donc nous avons bien sûr des
contrats via l'intérim
aujourd'hui la plateforme logistique du
groupe psa spécialisée dans les pièces
détachées emploie déjà 300 intérimaires
environ leur nombre pourrait doubler
préparateurs de commandes cariste pilote
d'installation robotisée encadrement
beaucoup de postes sont concernés par
ces embauches
le préfet s'est même déplacé en personne
pour assurer psa du soutien des services
de l'état je suis là pour lancer une
mobilisation
d'ailleurs je l'ait déjà lancé à deux
mois avec psa aussi tous les acteurs
l'agglomération la région le département
tous les partenaires de service public
de l'emploi
parce qu'il va y avoir des besoins
importants de recrutement sur une
période courte d'ici la fin de l'année
autour de 300 et qu'il est vraiment
indispensable que le département que
vesoul soir rendez vous de ces
recrutements
parce que c'est un test de crédibilité
une embellie contestée par les
représentants de la cgt syndicat
minoritaire qui n'a pas signé l'an passé
l'accord sur le temps de travail 37
heures 45 au lieu de 35 heures sans
compensation salariale intégral et la
réalité c'est qu'on supprime des postes
par le fait mécanique de l'augmentation
du temps de travail
on supprime des postes par le fait aussi
de la mécanisation qui a lieu en ce
moment à psa à vesoul et
c'est fait pour tout est fait pour le
profit bien sûr nous n'allons pas être
démagogique
si nous voulons continuer cette belle
aventure il faudra qu'on soit toujours à
la meilleure performance c'est celle du
marché et donc nous allons continuer à
nous améliorer mais aujourd'hui de fait
nous créons des emplois sur le site et
vous en avez la démonstration
aujourd'hui en augmentant sa
productivité
psa à vesoul a attiré de nouvelles
activités notamment celle du site
bientôt fermer d'hérimoncourt avec les
recrutements prévus
lusine de haute saône qui travaille aux
deux tiers pour l'étranger devraient
dépasser bientôt la barre des 3000
salariés